hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today i'm answering
a question from one of our youtube
viewers vtn link who wrote in asking
when were you the happiest thanks for
inspiration don't stop making videos so
thanks for the question and I'll make a
deal with you as long as you keep
watching videos I'll keep making them in
terms of your question when it was when
when was I the happiest i'm going to
give you two answers here the first was
when i sold my first you know real
business my software company it was one
of the the happiest moments i guess you
know we got a good price for made a lot
of money from it it was something we had
worked for years to put together and
build from nothing you know from an
apartment and we built it up and had you
know customers like NASA and johnson
johnson in over 30 countries and and
we'd work to sell the business and we
eventually did that and so there was a
great sense of elation happiness a lot
of overwhelming feelings of having sold
the business after you know making that
our goal to do so it was very intense
and intense high intense happiness what
I quickly found afterwards though was
now what do i do you know was I was not
happy as I wouldn't say depressed but
searching for something new to do and
not knowing what to do every day when I
woke up and I think what a lot of
entrepreneur's do is chase those highs
where what I ended up doing is trying to
find the business that would fulfill me
and make me happy every day and it's not
necessarily the great highs that I got
like when I was sold my business but I'm
much more fulfilled in what I do you
know I love what I do so much more now
so the helping entrepreneurs this
business started because after I sold my
software company I was asked to do a
whole bunch of speaking to help
entrepreneurs and
and got called in and hired to go you
know travel and help entrepreneurs in
different countries and that gave me a
greater sense of fulfillment and and
felt like what i was doing is really
helping people and that really spoke to
what i wanted to do is my next call in i
guess and so even in my day-to-day life
i wake up i get your emails I get your
comments on YouTube I get your facebook
comments and that makes me happy you
know I love seeing that we're having an
impact and that helping people stay
motivated their business and give them
ideas to help them grow their business
and it's it's a it's a deeper sense of
happiness I guess so the first one was
was such a high very acute and something
that you chase I guess and I don't think
I've necessarily gotten to that point
with with my current business but I wake
up a lot more fulfilled very happy about
what I do and feeling that I'm really
helping people and so I guess is a
different kind of happiness and I'm not
really chasing that big guy because I
enjoy what I do every day helping
entrepreneurs so two-part answer to your
question hopefully that helped for those
of you watching if you liked it please
give it a thumbs up below makes me want
to do more of these for you and if you
have a comment on this video if you
liked the video or not and or if you
want to ask me a question but your
business I'd love to be able to try to
answer it for you if you want to leave
it in the comment section below so thank
you and I'll see you in the next episode
you
bye